♪ ♪
>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
WE WILL DO A QUICK INTERVIEW
WITH ROB O'NEILL AND TALK ABOUT
THE STUFF THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU.
WHEN WE DECIDED TO TAKE OUT
ISIS -- I SAY WE AS IN THE END
AMERICA -- WE ANNIHILATED THEM
WAS AT 70, 100,000 FIGHTERS?
>> WE ANNIHILATED THEM AT FIRST,
THEN WE DECIDED TO LEAVE A
WAR ZONE AS A VACUUM, AS OPPOSED
TO BOMBING A --
I DON'T WANT TO BLAME ONE
PERSON, BAD DECISIONS ARE MADE
IN COMBAT ALL THE TIME.
KEEP THE BASE, BOMB THE BAD
GUYS.
THERE IS A PICTURE OF THEM IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL PALACE.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT LEFT,
AND HE HAD SO MUCH MONEY IN HIS
HELICOPTER HE COULDN'T CLOSE THE
DOOR.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> YES.
BUT THEY ARE TAKING PICTURES IN
HIS WEIGHT ROOM.
HERE'S A CRAZY IDEA, DROP A BOMB
ON THAT PLACE.
>> Greg: IF WE KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE, THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO DO.
HOW IRONIC, HIS NAME IS --
>> I NEVER EVEN PUT THAT
TOGETHER.
I'M GOING TO STEAL THAT JOKE.
>> Greg: PLEASE DO, YOU SURELY
NEED THEM.
>> NO OFFENSE, IN CASE YOU ARE
WONDERING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SKEPTICAL OF
THE NEW IMPROVED TALIBAN?
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THEM?
>> I ACTUALLY HAVE.
>> Greg: ARE WE
EXAGGERATING --
>> NO, THEY ARE REALLY BRUTAL,
BUT I DID HAVE TALIBAN GUYS TELL
ME, EATING RICE OUT OF THE SAME
BALL, BUT FOR SOME REASON --
THEY HAVE TOLD ME, IF THEY KNEW
WE WERE AS SERIOUS AS WE WERE AT
THE BEGINNING WITH THE BOMBING
AND THE FIGHTING, THEY WOULD
HAVE GIVEN US AL QAEDA.
MAYBE NOT, BECAUSE THEY ARE TWO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
AL QAEDA IS FOREIGN FIGHTERS IN
AFGHANISTAN, ANYWAY, AND I DON'T
SEE TALIBAN INTERESTED IN
ATTACKING US.
THEY WANT THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEY WANT THEIR MOUNTAINS BEARD
I WANT TO BE OPTIMISTIC --
HOPEFULLY, I'M PROBABLY WRONG,
BUT HOPEFULLY THEY JUST WANT TO
KEEP THEIR COUNTRY, NOT LET THE
PRESS INCOME AND JUST MURDER
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: HOW CAN CHINA --
>> BECAUSE CHINA WILL CRUSH YOU.
>> Greg: GOING TO GET ALL OF
THE MINERALS --
BATTERIES FORM I.E.-BIKE.
>> THE TALIBAN UNDERSTANDS, YOU
MESS WITH CHINA, THEY WILL KILL
YOU, LOOK AT THE UIGHURS.
THEY ARE BOTH HORRIBLE.
NOTICE THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY
DIDN'T CLOSE.
RUSSIA WILL KILL YOU.
WE DECIDE, BOY, I HOPE I DON'T
USE HARSH LANGUAGE.
>> Greg: WE ARE TOO BUSY
READING ANTIRACISM BOOKS --
>> WE ARE DOING --
WE HAVE BEEN PUTTING OUR OWN
TROOPS IN PRISON FOR MURDER IN A
WAR ZONE, WHICH AGAIN, I FEEL
LIKE I AM TAKING CRAZY PILLS.
IT'S FRUSTRATING TO SEE.
I HAVE TALKED TO SO MANY FRIENDS
TODAY, WHAT DID WE GO FOR?
IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING.
>> Greg: YEAH.
DID YOU GET ANYTHING FROM KAT,
BECAUSE THOSE WERE CRAZY PILLS.
>> YEAH, SHE SAID I WAS TAKING A
VACCINE.
>> Greg: DO YOU -- I HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO BRING UP HEROIN,
BUT IT FEELS THE TALIBAN
FINANCIALLY.
I WAS WONDERING, IF THAT WAS
THERE VODKA OR THEIR PART, WHY
DID WE NOT GO INTO BUSINESS WITH
THEM?
>> THEIR VODKA IS STILL VODKA,
THEIR POT IS STILL POPPED, IS
JUST THAT CHINA DOES NOT CARE
HOW THE MONEY COMES IN AND
NEITHER DOES RUSSIA.
WE ARE SO WOKE AND SO
POLITICALLY CORRECT, WE CAN
SCREW ANYTHING UP WITH WOKENESS.
WAIT AND SEE.
>> Greg: ALSO, THIS BOTCHED
EXIT WAS WITHOUT QUESTION ON THE
WORST, EXCEPT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMPARISON TO IT.
IS IT POSSIBLE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BAD NO MATTER WHAT?
>> YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
COMPARISON.
JOHN F. KENNEDY, FIRST IN
OFFICE, THE BAY OF PIGS, HE SAID
VICTORY HAS 100 FATHER'S.
DEFEAT HAS 0.
I WAS AN ORPHAN.
AND I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN CAME UP AND
SAID "I ACCEPT ALL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CLOSE TO
WHAT.
DOES THE BUCK STOPS HERE?
I'M NOT SEEING YOU ARE T